Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je vais vous parler
de communication alternative
ou comment faire quand la parole
ne nous permet pas d’exprimer
tout ce que nous aurions à dire.
Mais avant de vous expliquer pourquoi
ce sujet me tient autant à cœur,
j’aimerais vous lancer un petit défi
pour vous mettre dans le bain.
Je vous encourage vraiment à jouer le jeu.
Vous allez essayer de me faire
comprendre que vous voulez boire,
mais je vous mets une petite contrainte :
vous n’avez pas le droit de parler.
Allez-y, je vous regarde.
Ok, super, c’est allé très vite.
Merci. J’ai bien compris.
Maintenant, même contrainte,
même consigne, donc sans parler,
mais vous allez me faire comprendre
précisément ce que vous voulez boire,
votre boisson préférée par exemple.
Allez-y, je vous observe.
Je vois une bouteille qui s’ouvre.
Je vois des mouvements, des gestes.
Il y en a qui rigolent.
C'est vrai que ça met un peu mal à l'aise
de faire autrement qu'à son habitude.
Certains n’ont pas tenté.
Merci à vous.
Mais on voit que pour exprimer
une idée basique,
si nous avons l’usage de nos mains,
l’accès à certains codes,
on y arrive.
Mais pour aller plus loin, pour être plus
précis, nous sommes vite en difficulté.
Une seconde.
Et si vous aviez un tableau
de communication comme celui-ci ?
En version papier.
(Montre l’écran) En version technologique.
Je pourrais vous dire « boire ».
Je - veux - boire
du thé - avec - du lait.
Avec une synthèse vocale :
(Voix off) Je veux boire thé avec lait.
Avoir des supports visuels,
ça nous permet d’aller plus loin,
d’être plus précis
quand nous ne pouvons pas parler.
Cela nous aide aussi à comprendre.
Ce tableau est un exemple d’un outil
de communication alternative et augmentée.
Un petit exemple simple de CAA.
Communication alternative qui peut
remplacer la parole si elle est absente,
ou augmentée - on dit aussi
améliorée, mais c’est pareil -
quand on peut parler
mais qu’on est difficile à comprendre
ou qu’on n’a pas assez de mots
pour tout ce que l’on aurait à dire.
Donc c’est la CAA.
Il existe plein d’outils, évidemment,
qui permettent d’aller beaucoup plus loin.
En classe, par exemple,
pour permettre la pleine participation
d’un élève qui ne parle pas.
J’allais vous expliquer pourquoi
ce sujet me tient tant à cœur.
Parce que dans ma famille, nous utilisons
la communication alternative et augmentée
pour soutenir la communication de ma fille
qui est en situation de handicap.
Très tôt, bien avant
de parler de handicap,
encore moins de syndrome
génétique accidentel,
nous nous sommes rendu compte que la
communication n’allait pas aller de soi.
Je me revois à faire les marionnettes,
à faire « caché ! coucou ! »
avec ce bébé dont le visage
restait complètement figé, impassible.
Pas de sourire, de réaction,
et je me suis posé plein de questions.
Je me suis demandé
comment faisaient ces autres mamans
dont les bébés leur répondaient
par des sourires, des gazouillis,
par la suite, par des sons,
encore plus tard, par des mots.
C’était moi qui n’étais pas aussi drôle ?
Pourtant, j'y mettais du mien.
Et par hasard, par chance,
une amie m’a parlé de communication
alternative et augmentée.
Si le langage oral est difficile, il faut
faire autrement pour se faire comprendre.
La communication ne doit pas
attendre l’émergence de la parole.
Ah oui, c'est une évidence.
Donc pas de temps à perdre.
Juste avant ses trois ans,
nous avons commencé à proposer
des pictogrammes à ma fille,
à lui proposer des alternatives
à ce langage oral qui était si difficile.
Un de ses premiers mots,
c’était « balançoire ».
Elle nous montrait
le pictogramme de la balançoire
et nous partions en courant,
même sous la pluie, au fond du jardin
pour qu’elle voie
qu’elle avait son mot à dire,
que nous pouvions la comprendre,
que la communication, ça marche,
que la communication, c’est du pouvoir.
Et quelle joie pour elle
de découvrir qu’elle en avait.
Parce que quand la communication
est très difficile,
que nous n’arrivons pas
à nous faire comprendre,
soit cela se transforme en frustration,
exprimée souvent par des comportements
qui sont difficiles à vivre pour tous,
soit il arrive que la personne baisse
les bras, qu’elle devienne passive,
que démotivée, elle arrête de tenter,
ou bien qu’elle réduise son message
au strict essentiel.
Donc l’arrivée de la CAA pour ma fille,
comme pour des milliers d’autres,
c’était la découverte du plaisir
de se faire comprendre,
entendue et écoutée.
Parce que mettre en place la CAA,
ce n’est pas juste une question d’outil,
de classeur de pictogrammes,
de tablette, de synthèse vocale,
c’est surtout une posture,
une philosophie presque,
basée sur l’espoir,
sur la présomption du potentiel
de chaque personne.
C’est une acceptation de l’autre
dans sa différence
et une volonté de créer un espace
de communication partagé,
accessible à l’autre.
« Je ne te comprends pas ma fille,
mais je m’intéresse à toi
et je sais que tu as des choses à dire,
que tu n’arrives pas encore à exprimer. »
Il faut avoir l’audace
de croire au potentiel,
de mettre en place
des moyens de communication
sans savoir jusqu’où pourra aller
la personne que nous accompagnons.
Cela peut paraître un peu perché,
(Rit) un peu utopique.
Mais la loi internationale, l'expérience
clinique et la recherche scientifique
nous donnent raison.
Nous avons le droit, le devoir même,
de croire au potentiel des personnes
en situation de handicap de communication.
Si une personne a de très grandes
difficultés de communication,
il y a souvent une incertitude
par rapport à ses capacités cognitives.
Nous ne savons pas ce qu'elle sait,
ce qu'elle pense.
Et c’est d’autant plus vrai
s’il y a des défis moteurs
qui l’empêchent d’utiliser
ses mains, par exemple,
pour pointer, pour signer,
ou des défis sensoriels qui l’empêchent
de voir et d’entendre.
Et plus ces défis sont importants, plus
elle aura besoin de moyens alternatifs
pour pouvoir développer ses capacités
et exprimer son potentiel.
Sans moyens de communication adaptés,
elle ne pourra jamais nous montrer
ce dont elle est capable.
Donc il y a dix ans,
quand j’ai commencé à m’y intéresser,
la CAA était beaucoup moins développée
en France qu’elle ne l’est aujourd’hui.
Les outils étaient moins disponibles,
moins accessibles,
les demandes de financements
étaient souvent refusées.
Beaucoup de professionnels ne savaient
même pas que la CAA existait.
Et même quand ils connaissaient
les pictogrammes,
souvent ils pensaient qu’un enfant devait
prouver qu’il connaissait certains mots
avant de lui en donner d'autres.
Ils n’étaient pas au courant
de la recherche actuelle
sur l’importance de donner accès à un
vocabulaire qui est riche et bien organisé
pour que la personne puisse dire
précisément ce qu’elle veut.
Et aujourd’hui, eh bien, malheureusement,
nous faisons encore face à beaucoup
de ces mêmes barrières.
Cela avance, vite même, mais pas assez.
Saviez-vous que si un enfant ne parle pas
à l’âge de quatre ans, six ans,
même dix ans,
il ne se voit pas
systématiquement proposer
des moyens de communication alternative ?
Cela reste encore une histoire de chance.
Mais il y a une communauté grandissante
de familles, de professionnels,
de personnes utilisatrices de CAA
qui militent chaque jour
pour le droit à la communication,
le droit d’avoir une voix
et d’être entendu.
Et j’aimerais que vous rejoigniez
cette communauté-là,
cette famille CAA élargie.
Deux millions de personnes en France
sont concernées par un handicap
de communication.
Cela représente presque 3% de la
population à un moment donné dans sa vie.
Les raisons sont très diverses :
des syndromes génétiques comme ma fille,
mais aussi l’autisme,
la paralysie cérébrale,
la trisomie 21 et encore et encore.
Il y a aussi tout ce qui est maladie
ou accident, un AVC par exemple.
N’importe qui d’entre nous peut être
impacté à un moment donné
par un handicap de communication.
Aujourd'hui, les outils existent.
Le droit international protège
le droit à la communication.
La Convention internationale relative
aux droits des personnes handicapées
parle spécifiquement de communication
alternative et améliorée.
Mais la difficulté aujourd'hui, c'est que
la majorité des personnes concernées
n’ont toujours pas accès aux outils
accompagnées par des personnes
formées à leur utilisation.
Mais...
Mais pourquoi ?
Pourquoi ceux qui en ont besoin
n’auraient pas accès aux outils ?
Il y a plusieurs raisons, mais il existe
un phénomène malheureusement courant.
Il s’agit de sous-estimer
les capacités et le potentiel
des personnes en situation de handicap,
et notamment en situation
de handicap de communication.
On pense que parce qu’ils ne peuvent pas
parler, ils n’ont rien à dire.
On pose parfois des diagnostics
de déficience intellectuelle sévère
alors que la personne
n’a jamais eu de moyens
pour exprimer sa compréhension,
son intelligence,
pour utiliser le langage
pour interagir avec son entourage,
poser des questions,
développer ses capacités.
Un professionnel m’a mise en garde de
ne pas trop stimuler ma fille handicapée,
que je devais faire le deuil
de l’enfant parfait,
que si je cherchais des moyens
pour l’aider à communiquer,
c’était parce que j’étais
dans le déni du handicap.
Et pourtant,
pour moi, c’est tout le contraire.
Cette enfant que j’ai,
cette enfant que j’aime,
c’est justement parce que je vois
en toute lucidité ses difficultés
que je milite pour son droit à des
opportunités riches et des moyens adaptés.
Est-ce que l’on souhaite rester
sur l’idée, pourtant désuète,
que la capacité à s’exprimer à l’oral
reflète la capacité à entendre,
à réfléchir, à rêver ?
Non.
Ce n’est pas parce que nous n’arrivons pas
à exprimer nos idées
que nous n'en avons pas.
Et même,
je vous invite à découvrir une citation
de l’astrophysicien Steven Hawking,
sans doute un des utilisateurs de CAA
les plus célèbres à ce jour :
« Les personnes silencieuses ont
les esprits les plus bruyants. »
Comme quoi, la CAA, ça ne sert pas
que pour demander à boire.
Mais Steven Hawking était déjà
un astrophysicien renommé
avant de tomber malade.
S’il était né avec son handicap, il aurait
eu le même potentiel intellectuel,
mais est-ce qu’il aurait eu
les opportunités
pour développer ses capacités ?
Est-ce que l’on aurait reconnu
son potentiel ?
Aujourd’hui, heureusement,
de plus en plus d’enfants et d’adultes
qui étaient historiquement considérés
comme étant incapables d’apprendre,
incapables de communiquer,
eh bien, ils commencent à avoir accès à
des outils qui sont adaptés à leurs défis,
mais ambitieux dans leur conception.
Même avec une tablette grand public,
même parfois un téléphone,
nous avons accès aujourd’hui
à des applications très performantes
qui permettent de s'exprimer pleinement.
Et nous avons aussi des technologies
comme la commande oculaire
qui permet d’utiliser ses yeux
pour contrôler un ordinateur, une tablette
et donc une synthèse vocale.
Et grâce à ces avancées,
nous avons plein de surprises
sur les capacités des personnes.
Dans une étude d’impact de la Croix-Rouge,
86% des professionnels interrogés
ont dit avoir découvert des compétences
qu’ils ne soupçonnaient pas
chez les personnes qu’ils accompagnaient
grâce à la communication alternative.
Et c’est aussi
notre expérience de parents :
la CAA nous permet
de mieux connaître nos enfants.
Parfois de toutes petites choses.
Comme cette maman qui m’a raconté
que son enfant de dix ans
avait pu demander son dessert
pour la première fois de sa vie.
Et parfois des découvertes
qui bousculent complètement
notre compréhension de qui ils sont.
Comme pour ses enseignantes qui ont
découvert que certains de leurs élèves,
diagnostiqués pourtant avec un
polyhandicap, savaient lire et écrire.
Et ma fille.
Aujourd'hui, elle a treize ans.
Elle parle maintenant
et elle continue aussi à utiliser
la communication alternative et augmentée
pour des mots qu’elle oublie
ou qu’elle n’arrive pas à prononcer,
pour l’aider à écrire
et pour raconter des souvenirs.
Parler de ses spectacles de fauconnerie
préférés, par exemple,
une grande passion pour elle.
Ce serait peut-être
une histoire plus inspirante
si je pouvais vous dire
que ma fille est une génie,
avec des capacités
intellectuelles inespérées
enfouies dans un corps
qui ne l’écoute pas.
Mais ce ne serait pas vrai.
Ces histoires existent,
mais elles appartiennent
à d’autres familles, à d’autres individus.
Ceux qui ne seront pas astrophysiciens,
ou écrivains,
ils ont tout autant le droit de
s’exprimer, d’être entendus et respectés.
Même pouvoir dire
que l’on aime telle musique
ou que l’on préfère
boire du coca que du thé,
eh bien, ça a son importance.
Et pouvoir dire que quelqu’un
nous a fait peur ou mal,
c’est essentiel pour sa sécurité.
D’autant plus pour un public
qui est, statistiquement,
beaucoup plus vulnérable aux abus.
Donc concrètement, comment faire ?
Proposons des tableaux de communication
dans tous les lieux publics -
les crèches, les classes,
les hôpitaux, les bars, partout -
pour ceux qui sont
en difficulté de communication
et aussi pour faire connaître la CAA.
Proposons des moyens de communication
dès le plus jeune âge
et dès que l’on voit qu’un enfant
a un retard de communication,
proposons-lui un moyen de communication
qui permettrait de dire
tout ce qu’un autre enfant
du même âge pourrait dire.
Pour les parents :
n’acceptez pas que
l’on vous dise d’attendre.
La communication est un droit.
Et le meilleur moment, c'est maintenant.
Si un enfant est à l’école
ou en établissement.
Accès à la CAA partout et tout le temps,
mais aussi une vraie place prioritaire
pour l’apprentissage de la lecture
et de l’écriture pour tous les élèves,
y compris ceux qui sont les
plus impactés par le handicap.
Savoir écrire, cela permet
une vraie liberté de communication.
Que l’on arrête d’entendre :
« Il ne parle pas. »
et que l’on réponde :
« Ah, c’est dommage ! »
et que la conversation s’arrête là
comme si c’était une fatalité.
Si le langage oral est difficile,
insuffisant,
il faut faire autrement
pour se faire comprendre.
Il ne s’agit pas
de vouloir un enfant parfait,
juste un enfant, ou une personne,
qui a la possibilité d’atteindre
son vrai potentiel.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)